So here we are. Back to our overarching design.
And you'll notice that, thus far we've created just the
one instance of our class movie. And that instance
is, Toy Story. The next thing for us to do,
is create another instance of class movie. And this
time we're going to create Avatar. So, to do that, I
am back here at my code. Here's the code
for the class movie. And, here is my entertainment_center.py file, which
is where I'm creating my first instance, Toy Story.
Now, you may have noticed that I've reduced the font
size of my code, this is so I can squeeze
all of the code, in one video frame so you
can see it properly. Next, I will create the
instance called avatar, by calling media.Movie. The first piece of
information I have to supply, is the name of the
movie, which is Avatar. Next is its storyline, which is,
a marine on an alien planet. That is followed by, Avatar's movie poster,
which I will paste here. And the final piece of information is, Avatar's YouTube
trailer, which I will also copy in. All right. So, here is our new
instance, Avatar. Let's print out it's storyline
next. So I will say, print avatar.storyline.
There it is. I'm also going to comment out
my previous print statement, which was printing out twice toy
story, story line. So, there it is, let me go
ahead and save this file. Now before I go ahead and
run this program, let me ask you a question. What
do you think, will be the output of this line
of code right here? Now I know that the font
of this code is really difficult to read. So what I'm
going to do, is make it a little bit bigger. So here it is,
the code in a bigger font size. Here is where we are creating the
instance avatar, and here we're trying to print it story line. So, what do
you think will be the output of
the following code? Here are some answer choices.